[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
during the commercial break paulie goes
you know what you should ask dean
blandino do the referees do they bring
their shirt to the uh the stadium or is
it there for them
do they own their own shirts
who decides how tight the shirts are
let's bring in dean blandino fox nfl
college football rules analyst former
vice president of officiating
all right dean let me uh entertain and
humor paulie can you answer those
questions about the referees their their
uniforms yeah i mean the hard-hitting
questions starting right off the bat
yeah i know so
um
they they own their own uniforms they
they bring them to the game with them so
it's not you don't show up in the locker
room and the uniforms are all pressed
and waiting for you so they're
responsible and uh and
i guess fortunately or unfortunately in
some situations they do go on their own
and tailor their own shirts and
we've seen the the result of that
they're not supposed to but they do they
get fitted before the year and and uh
they get new uniforms every year but
they're responsible for uh maintaining
and washing and the upkeep okay wait a
minute they're not supposed to taper
their jersey
no they're they're not supposed to once
they get they get they get their
measurements they get tailored uh
they're not supposed to make any
any uh what off-market changes and uh
they uh you know as you can see you know
there's a lot of tinted windows out
there
okay is this the ed hoculey rule
yeah i think it is i think it is and you
know it's interesting i think we're
seeing more of it i don't know how much
college football you watch but it seems
to have entered into the college
football realm where some of these
referees in college have taken the ed
the ad hocule you know routine and to
another level i think we're in you know
the the sports science the the nutrition
i think we're we're on another level
right now
that's really all we wanted to talk to
you about dude but uh while i have you i
should ask you a couple of things
we're seeing targeting in college
football and it felt like the first two
weeks there is a real emphasis on that
and i don't know where we're headed and
how that impacts the nfl if it does are
they apples to apples or apples to
oranges
well i think they both they're they're
kind of apples to they're maybe granny
smith to to fuji they're they're they're
apples but they're not exactly the same
because obviously the targeting rule you
have the automatic disqualification nfl
has a a hit on defenseless player it's
more or less the same rule you can't hit
to the head neck area you can't use the
helmet to initiate contact uh but you
don't have the disqualification i think
we've seen this every year there seems
to be an uptick early i think the you
know the the players are just you know
getting used to game speed they're
they're not practicing at the same at
the same intensity and maybe they put
themselves in a position during games
that they don't normally in practice the
officials are getting used to it but it
tends to to regulate itself over the
course of the season you see an uptick
early but over the last three years it's
we've averaged in fbs and fcs one
disqualification every five games so so
it's not like it's happening all that
often and uh and and so i think in the
nfl rule the defenseless player rule is
working and and so i think both rules
work uh but you're you're gonna have
games and weeks where you might have a
little bit of a an increase in fouls and
sometimes you just you know just it is
what it is sometimes the games play out
that way is it just me or it feels like
every year in the nfl
there was uh emphasis on past
interference and then uh
a couple years ago it was holding and
then tom brady tweeted out you know
don't want to watch this so many holding
calls
it like
is there an emphasis on one particular
call or penalty every year
that you start the year with
there usually is and that that process
the competition committee they they
start meeting during the season in terms
of conference calls and things like that
then once the season ends they really
pick up their their schedule
and uh and they they they look at all
the trends from the season a lot of that
is right passing yards per game that's
an important number points per game
plays per game so they look at all of
that and if they notice anything that's
an issue then they'll dive into the tape
and see okay are we are we not calling
fouls in certain areas are we missing
fouls i think this year um illegal
contact will be the one that will
probably be talking about at least early
on because last year there were only 36
fouls
in 272 games that's the lowest in
history and that that foul that's your
defensive players can't contact beyond
five yards you know that goes back to
the to the 70s that rule and uh and that
impacts the passing game passing yards
were down last year for the first time
it was the second lowest since 2010 so
that's that's somewhat of a concern so
you have to look at you know are we not
calling illegal contact are we allowing
defenders to disrupt routes and disrupt
the timing downfield illegally so
that'll be a point of emphasis i think
we'll see an uptick early and those are
big penalties they're five yards but
they're automatic first downs um so i i
would be i would expect to see some of
that early in the season how much
pressure did you feel when you're the
vice president of officiating
to have more offense to ensure that
there would be more offense in the game
yeah there wasn't
we never said i never had anybody tell
me hey we need we need more offense we
need more points i think it's a balance
but when you look at you look at
plays per game that's number one and
sometimes that get that gets lost
because that's that's the game that's
what you know people don't go to the
stadium or watch on tv to watch people
stand around and we have a lot of down
time in in both nfl and college and so
you want to make sure that your plays
per game 155 plus per game um and then
you're always looking people don't want
to watch you know i talked about the
illegal contact rule back in the 70s and
you know just having just studied it
um you know the game had started to
stagnate in the early 70s it became more
of a running game the nfl wasn't the
most popular sport as and and or league
as it is today the illegal contact rule
really opened up the passing game and
that led to the popularity that the nfl
has today so that's
you know it's it's always an underlying
theme that we've got to monitor that
because that's that's what makes the
game as popular as it is today where are
we with roughing the passer
now as opposed to the last couple of
years
yeah i i hope that we're getting to a
better place last year there were there
were 153 rough in the passer falls call
that that was the highest in history and
the league i think got together with the
committee the officiating department and
they really studied it and they and they
came out in the off season and they said
hey
we called some fouls that we probably
shouldn't have last year and the focus
was on
in two areas
forcible contact to the head neck and
the and the hit to the knee area or
below and they felt there were some
fouls last year where it really wasn't
forcible it was more of a incidental
contact and they showed all the
officials the referees specifically
because they're the ones that are
responsible for that primarily and uh
and said hey these are not fouls
it's a point of emphasis the low hit
they really want to see that forcible
contact um if a defender you know can
get off to the side and just and just
grab and pull the quarterback to the
ground so i think we're gonna see that
number drop and i'm hoping that we get
to a a good place where we're not
because those as you know those are
15-yard penalties those are big big
calls and those can change games and and
you certainly want it to be there to to
have that foul ball where are we with
taunting nfl as opposed to college
yeah you know college is a is a much
higher standard in terms of of you can't
in college you can't even spike the ball
on a touchdown there's really no the nfl
has really loosened up on the
celebration rules um so there's more in
the nfl in terms of celebrating and
doing things after a touchdown or after
a big play but the taunting rule i mean
it's very similar in both where you
can't do anything directed at an
opponent that was obviously the point of
emphasis last year that got so much
attention
and and again you could debate whether
the league went too far and i think
there were some incidents where yeah it
probably wasn't enough uh but the league
the competition committee is not backing
off the direction to the officiating
department and the on-field officials is
the same
you can celebrate you can do things with
your teammates you can do but if you do
anything directed at an opponent that
crosses that line that's going to be a
foul i think any time you see that
emphasis year two it always tends to be
a little better the players are used to
it the coaches are used to it so i
wouldn't imagine as many fouls but
they're not they're not backing off on
it
what's the oddest moment you ever had
when the commissioner called you
uh the oddest moment um
i mean i i have a he's he's great i wish
people could see
the the the personal side of roger
goodell we get to see kind of the
front-facing and the media and the press
conferences
um you know he's great i had an i had a
situation um
a couple of years back where i was seen
on a on a certain we won't name names
but a certain organization they've got a
big bus with a big star on it and uh and
i was on that bus for a little social
gathering and it happened to make make
some media news attention and he he and
i had a good conversation and he was
just you know it was it was a funny
conversation about him because obviously
uh he's had experience with that with
that organization and so that was
probably i won't get into too many
details but that was probably my most uh
interesting conversation with him did
you get verbally spanked for being on
the cowboys but
it was more like uh you know
just you know when you talk to your kids
it's not quite a spanking but it's uh
you you know what you did right come on
let's
let's let's uh let's pick it up a little
bit
it was a point of emphasis
yeah it was a point of emphasis that
year and going forward not to be on any
party buses
thank you buddy uh good to talk to you
all right take care dean blandino fox
nfl college football rules analyst
former vp
of officiating